good morning Chris how are you good
morning
we're doing okay is this a day off yeah
you know there's no there's no real days
off in pro football but this would be
yeah like officially a day off but could
you just say I'm gonna have beer and
wings and this lay around and not do
anything
no I doesn't work when you get older did
you watch the Rams last night your your
former team yeah you know I got a lot of
friends on a team obviously so you know
check it out just like that was bad last
night Chris well you know everybody has
bad games you know they got some good
players oh no pick it up and turn around
was there a part of you that like that
opportunity to go to Los Angeles were
you looking forward to then you know I
literally such a one-day-at-a-time guy
you know I never thought about it and
this is something you know talked about
at length but anytime somebody's going
through that situation you know with all
the talk about listen or whatever guys
are so focused on their performance and
day today and you don't take anything
for granted like I'm not you know I'm
gonna be here next year or so on and so
forth so you're not thinking about that
stuff so I never did think about that
stuff the difference of your first game
with the Patriots and as opposed to
playing with the Rams well I'm not going
I'm not gonna go down the comparison
road because you know I have played in
so many different situation I played on
two teams I've played for so many
different head coaches and I can speak
for the fact that you know the other
night was a lot of fun it was a good
team when it really was a team when it
took everybody and being want to know is
really hard to do in the NFL it's hard
to get that first win but you know we
are on them Miami look at you you're
sounding Patriot like I'm on the
Patriots were you on the field for the
potential game-winning field goal I was
not
I think I'm bad luck with that stuff so
why is that part of the scouting report
don't put Chris long on the field during
a potential game-winning field goal I
don't know but uh listen you know it
it's every place tough to make in the
NFL so nothing's nothing's you can't
take anything for granted you know it
was a hard-fought ballgame and you know
there were a lot of things they could
have won or lost the game on both sides
and out of that so how long do you want
to play like I said and I'm really not
copping out I am a day-to-day guy um I
just it takes so much energy to play pro
football I'm really saying you know
would you can't take your health for
granted you know you can't take your
performance for granted you have to go
out and and work every week and so I
don't think about that I really really
don't um I just think about having the
best year if Tom Brady's car is broken
down on the side of the road are you
allowed to stop and help them but you
can't talk you can't talk football with
him talk about the world Paulie has he's
just not sure how to handle the
handsomeness of Garoppolo and he had he
had some thoughts for you to see if
maybe you could shed shed a light up
Paulie would you uh ask Chris well
there's a lot of debate here Chris about
the easy transition at quarterback from
the Hansen is a Brady to the handsome
mr. Garoppolo it's got to be easy for
the team right I don't know man
a lot of people yeah I think the guy is
tough for is Julian Edelman he thinks
he's like Tom Cruise or something so
this is kind of making him feel awkward
you know the attention shifted from his
like where they call that like a butt
chin he's got you know neckbeard I mean
like women love Julian Edelman so it's
uh it's been a tough transition for him
now everybody's paying attention to
Jimmy
yeah I don't know if he's given Jimmy
everything he can because it felt like
he was really sad he said that it's like
Tom is going to prison he's going to
jail come on yeah yeah I don't know are
you done with tattoos Seaton wants to
know since he's our resident tattoo
expert why not right now oh my my dad
wants me here but you know it's already
like a circus freak so you just keep
going well your dad said once you guys
got bigger than him that he couldn't
stop you from getting tattoos now I
don't know he couldn't stop colic I
wanted to do it but yeah I'm still
smaller in him so he can act like that
if he wants it's just a generational
thing I mean you look back in the 80s
there wasn't a whole lot of guys with
tattoos were there I don't think so
but I found out on Sunday Terry Bradshaw
has a tattoo
I think it's Alpha and Omega I think
it's start and yeah so I don't know
where it is on his blonde its Bradshaw
who knows I didn't know he was bilingual
I think Terry has problems with English
let alone yeah but he he's got a tattoo
you can't a man your dad wouldn't get
one right with him or something at some
point in my life I think there's an
outside chance but it's not going to be
like he'd never get like sleeved up like
late in life like God like like Sly
Stallone you know Owens got a sleeve and
everybody's like what you know some guys
you know just eventually come around to
it I don't see my dad doing that I
didn't know Stallone as a sleeve I knew
either half sleeve I think oh is it like
the rock no I mean like it's not like
The Rock's tattoos like so I went like
with color and he got some big-time
artist to do it looks pretty good
big salon fans so like whatever he does
I support it
you know Paulie showing it to me right
now chest back shoulder Wow
yeah you got pretty good work and it's
like throws everybody off especially the
makeup artist when he does a movie
probably got to cover those suckers up
yeah yeah yeah
I know Johnny Depp does when he does
movies hey uh yeah you got have you been
to Fenway to see again you know I've
been in the Boston one time since I've
been here in the spring you know I I'm
here to work and Foxborough is a
wonderful area and you know I got
everything I need in that in that
immediate area I got we really do have
every everything we need to be
successful here and Boston is an awesome
City man it's awesome but I just traffic
just makes me like have a panic attack
or something I don't know what you would
call it but I sit in traffic and I lose
it so I try to avoid it what are you
driving now I Drive a Toyota Tundra oh
but you have a classic okay
you had classic cars for a long time
didn't you well yeah in Virginia I Drive
a 1992 SJ 16 to 60 to Atlanta oh yeah
this is the tank well I'm Victoria otter
guy good luck in the next game on to who
do you got Miami Miami yeah unball team
made really tough in Seattle and gonna
create a lot of challenges for us so
we're breaking them down today on film
that's what an off day is you know
that's that's the way we do it with the
Patriots it's the patriot way Chris yeah
you guys are like that no days off
hashtag no days off sometimes it seems
like we take a lot of days off Chris
even when we're doing this hey good to
talk to you good luck there and thanks
for joining us good talking all right
that's a crystal on the Dan Patrick show
we
on audience